[Music]
all right hello
humanoids of youtube i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report direct message it's
a friday panel
extravaganza for june 4th 2021 as always
click that subscribe button
tap that notification bell and there's a
chance albeit a small chance that you
will see our videos
in your youtube feed we got three
stories for you today we're going to be
talking about this trove
of emails that have been released from
the faucist anthony fauci and i'm only
actually we're only going to cover one
specifically we'll probably talk about a
few of them uh but there's just so many
things leaking out right now and
you're not gonna believe it guys but all
the people we all called conspiracy
theorists three months ago yeah they
were pretty much
right about everything which is pretty
much consistent with everything else
going on in the world
and then there's uh the second story
which is about that joe biden guy he's
the 78 year old guy with dementia that's
pretending that he's president of the
united states
he's also a racist we'll get to that in
just a moment uh and then the third
story
which actually this one hits a little
close to home for me my friend
andy know who i can actually call a
journalist without having to use air
quotes
uh he was violently attacked in portland
and had to hide in a hotel it's actually
the very
hotel that a couple years ago i met andy
at for the first time
uh and then and then twitter did some
really crazy stuff changing they took
journalist out of the trending topic
because some activists went after them
for calling him a journalist and a whole
bunch of other stuff
he is doing okay i actually spoke to him
this morning but before i intro
my esteemed panel i want to talk to you
guys about gabby insurance
you know there are hundreds of companies
out there claiming to compare auto
and home insurance rates but there's
only one who actually does it
get a better insurance with gabby gabby
is the one true
comparison platform with fast verifiable
quotes not
ballpark guesses use your current policy
to find a better policy
comparing your current coverage with 40
of the top insurance providers like
progressive
nationwide and travelers all in one
place
use your current insurance information
to get started it's free and they only
show you policies that are the same
or better than your current coverage
many of them at a lower
price when i used the gabby calculator i
discovered great insurance quotes within
minutes and was quickly able to compare
the top
five rates by seeing them listed in
order which made navigating through the
plan super easy
they have great customer service and
support as well i'm now confident i have
the best insurance price available
gabby customers save 961 dollars per
year on average
and they'll never sell your info so no
annoying spam or robo calls
put your policy to the test like i did
get a better insurance with gabby
it's totally free to check and there's
no obligation go to gabby.com
ruben that's gabi.com reubengabby.com
ruben and now back to me okay here we go
we got a big panel for you joining me
today
are the senior editor at human events
and author of
the antifa stories from inside the black
box block finally jack pasobic
is joining us on the reuben report we've
got prageru personality amala
epinobi and author of the fauchian
bargain the most powerful
and dangerous bureaucrat in american
history
steve dees guys welcome to the reuben
report
hey guys super excited to be here thanks
thank you for having me
i think that was the longest intro that
i've ever done we're gonna we're gonna
start with
uh this fouchy stuff because i know you
guys have been all over it
on twitter and these emails are leaking
out like crazy and i was talking to my
team this morning about which emails we
should cover
uh i'm gonna read one email for you here
and then and then i'll let you guys
chime in here we go this is from
anthony fauci dr fauci masks
are really for infected people to
prevent them from spreading infection to
people who are not infected
rather than protecting uninfected people
from acquiring infection
the typical mask you buy in the
drugstore is
not really effective in keeping out
virus
which is small enough to pass through
the material
it might however provide some slight
benefit
in keep out gross droplets if someone
coughs or sneezes on you
i do not recommend that you wear a mask
particularly
since you're going to a very low risk
location your instincts are correct
money is best spent on medical counter
measures
such as diagnostics and vaccines so this
is an email that fauci sent a few months
ago
to a friend who had inquired as i think
they were going on vacation
or something like that steve i'm going
to let you chime in first because you've
got the book
fouchy and bargain i mean talk about
timing man jesus
i mean this is completely counter to
pretty much everything fouchy
and the rest of the crew have been
telling us for the last couple of months
how did you know
how did you know well we we decided why
don't we just research
the the data and go with what it says
rather than
the science of uh projecting political
narratives
brother the only science that evolves
this fast is political science can i get
an amen
all right all right
all of the and i mean all of the studies
we have done on this
for decades all showed that masks don't
work
against uh aerosols they don't work
against
airborne viruses in fact it was about
almost exactly one year ago
that current biden uh covet advisor
michael osterholm was addressing
was addressing the chamber of commerce
in minneapolis who were like dude we got
to stop losing money when can we reopen
why don't we just have everybody wear
masks and ulster home laughs and says
they don't work it's like trying to put
a screen door on a
submarine eventually you're gonna breed
these masks you know they're open and
the sides the air just gets out
it doesn't it doesn't do any good the
lie that you were told from the
beginning that the reason the masks work
because
the the virus predominantly spread by
droplets it does not
it's an airborne virus that's why the
mass don't work that's why you haven't
worn
masks every cold and flu season your
entire lives they don't work
and so the the question we should be
asking guys
is if they would have expressed this
level of we're not sure what we're up
against can you guys try this
you know we don't know that we can trust
what the chinese are selling us
we're going to kind of do a swiss cheese
thing we're going to deliver several
layers
to try to you know cover as many holes
as possible maybe we would have been
more uh willing to go along instead they
just denied all their own data
i mean cdc dave is doing this today
claiming that there's this whole
influx of icu patients of adolescence
when that's just simply not true by
their own data
they speak with certainty about things
that we can empirically prove
are not true why do they do that all the
answers to that question are bad
so jack i never tell people to be on
twitter but what you're one of the few
people that i actually enjoy
following on twitter you don't make me
crazy that's pretty much the highest
compliment i can give somebody but
the line alone the typical mask you buy
in a drugstore is not really effective
in keeping out a virus to me that should
sink him right there i know you've been
tracking all the other emails and you
can chime in on any of the other stuff
that he said
but isn't that alone a year and a half
after two weeks to flatten the curve
enough that this guy needs to go
well this is the same type of dynamic
you see with dr fauci when it comes to
things he says in private versus things
he says
in public now we do know in public
around the same time
he was also had a few comments a few
interviews
where he was basically saying the same
thing that hey these masks aren't
effective we need to save them for
doctors etc etc
but then he flips on a dime when it
comes to this stuff
and it's the same problem that we see
with the wuhan lab theory right
so we're talking about these gain of
function experiments we're talking about
could this have been something that came
out of that lab it's you know right down
the street from where
the chinese government is telling us
this thing broke out but fauci's out
there publicly
in one hand saying no this isn't
possible look at this lancet letter
uh you know there's nothing that you
need to worry about but in private
what we see in these emails is that he
has the very same questions that every
other researcher
every other journalist is looking at
people in their homes are asking about
when they hear about this stuff what do
you mean there's a lab right down the
street
right and so the problem i see and i
completely agree with steve on this
that he has one sort of take internally
where he's asking the questions and
seemingly acting like a normal person
would
and he didn't show that publicly he
publicly made pronouncements
he made proclamations the government
made proclamations based on this
they didn't come clean they weren't open
with us and now you've even got today
what
speaking about that landsat letter that
came out february of 2020
that really shut down the lab league
theory early on there's a guy out of
mount sinai
who actually wants to take his name off
the letter now he says you know what
i think there's been a lot of more
that's come out on this there's a lot
more smoke around that wuhan lab
let's investigate it it seems like that
has been
the critical mass point that's being
reached and that letter is falling apart
jack i feel like i got to give you an
opportunity to speak directly to
fouchy in chinese do you want to give
him a sentence
in
the american people deserve the truth
the chinese people deserve the truth
and the people of the world deserve the
truth about wuhan
pretty sure we just got our promo clip
for the show
what do you what do you think just
generally i'm pretty sure you're the
youngest on the panel here
that seems to me i didn't age you guys
right before but it seems to me that
that people your age like people in
their early 20s basically are looking
at the entire professional class the
entire elite class and going
you guys are just liars about absolutely
everything is that do you think that's
an overestimation
i would not say that's an overestimation
by any means i certainly
have found it very hard to trust
anything that comes out in terms of
advisement or regulation around this
virus and we've been proven right time
and time again we're not conspiracy
theorists as many people called us
and i think it's going to keep happening
a red flag for me with dr faushi was
last summer when all the blm riots were
happening
and he refused to make a statement that
the riots and the protests had any
effect
on the spreading of covet 19. that set
up a red flag for me immediately and now
we're seeing
all the the smoke and the fog be cleared
and we're seeing the man behind the
curtain so it's not surprising at all
and i find it uh really i think that
young people are not going to be able to
trust what's coming out
regarding this anymore steve since in
the subtitle of the book it's the most
dangerous
uh sorry the most powerful and dangerous
bureaucrat in american history
can you just talk about how we're just
kind of governed by mid-level
bureaucrats that nobody really knows and
that they
are the ones that are then you know in
effect telling biden what to do and then
biden just signs stuff or gavin newsom
here in california
and next thing you know it's a year
later and you haven't left your house
i think that's a really important point
dave it's the introduction to
the book begins with that that anthony
fauci
is a construct if he had retired he's 80
years old
if he had retired and taken his glorious
pension into the sunset as most people
do at his age or even years beforehand
i don't know that things would have
turned out much differently another
creature would have emerged from the
black lagoon
who knows it might have been debbie
bedazzle your face shield berks
um who knows it might have been francis
collins who went from one of the the
great scientific achievements of the age
the mapping of the human genome
in the 1990s and 2000s to wearing a
double mask outdoors after being
vaccinated
but it would have been somebody else the
system would have offered up someone
else that's what we do
in this technocracy uh we quote from
dwight eisenhower's farewell address and
everybody always talks about the
military industrial complex that he
warned us about but in that same speech
dave he warns about
the scientific age that we're on the
brink of the advancements now that that
we're on the brink of and to enjoy the
blessings of those but
don't let the people responsible for
them create themselves as sort of this
perpetual expert of class of of
unassailable bureaucrats that we then
seed our freedoms over to
that is exactly what we've done we
didn't listen to ike
jack do you think trump's feeling pretty
good right now like
it's basically over a year ago where he
said yeah there's kind of some evidence
that this thing was leaked
and suddenly everyone's now talking
about it at least that the possibility
that
it was leaked and yet you know he was
called a conspiracy theorist and a
warmonger and a racist
when he said it back in april of last
year well that's exactly right i mean he
was the guy who came out and said we
need to put this ban on
travel from china because everybody was
looking at the situation saying why is
it that china i'm i'm reading chinese
media back in
you know january 2020 translating it
flipping it over
into english putting on twitter and
everyone's saying wait china
is banning travel domestically so
internal travel
right between buhan beijing wuhan and
other major population centers
but they're not banning international
travel so they're still
you still got that huge travel pipeline
of chinese businessmen and tourists and
travelers
between the people's republic in italy
with the united states so it's trump
who's the first world leader that really
comes out and says
shut it down right you know we don't
want this traveling war the very next
day joe biden calls him
a xenophobe he says you are xenophobic
and a racist right
so when you're looking at this guy in
biden's defense later he said it wasn't
exactly because of that he meant it more
generally or something like that
right right that that his defense was no
i even though it was you know just i
think less than 12 hours
after the travel ban he said no no i
just meant he's in general a racist
that was their response amala the cries
of uh
racism they kind of don't work anymore
do they
no they don't they're not working on
people anymore and when it comes to the
cold hard facts of the situation he was
out to protect us he was out to do
right by the american people and you can
only use racism so much and i think the
left is
hopefully going to learn that very soon
because they're on this rampage of just
racism racism racism
and people are waking up to that well
that's a perfect segue actually for the
second story so
uh this is some video we're gonna show
you from townhall.com joe biden
was giving a speech and if you ever ever
want to know what the soft bigotry of
low expectations
is well listen to old joe the data shows
young black entrepreneurs are just as
capable of succeeding given the chance
as white entrepreneurs are
but they don't have lawyers they don't
have they
they don't have accountants but they
have great ideas
does anyone doubt this whole nation be
better off
from the investments those people make
and i promise you that's why i set up
this
national small business administration
that's much broader
because they're going to get those loans
amelia i'm uh reviewing my paperwork
here you are black
is that correct i am indeed that is very
true
i want to stay for the record i don't
see color dave thank you go ahead
steve you are definitely not black i
mean i i can't see that
olive i am olive yes uh so amelia
do you have a lawyer or an accountant
and if not do you need help finding one
we live
really kind of closely here
i do not currently have a lawyer or an
accountant but if i needed one i'm sure
that i could use my faculties to to get
one for myself
seriously though when you hear a
statement like that like what does that
make you feel make you think like like
that
is racism man that is racism
it is on its very face it's racism and
it's a big part of what made me leave
the left like you said the soft bigotry
of low expectations so now we can add to
the list that black people can't get
lawyers
they can't get accountants they can't
get voter id they can't get into college
without help from anybody
they need their businesses elevated on
platforms like youtube
and netflix and uber eats it's just they
expect so little of us because we are
the victims of american society
apparently
jack i mean obviously you're not a uh
abide in supporter but are you
shocked at how quickly this thing has
just completely
derailed or at least become everything
that a bunch of us warned it was going
to become
you know so i'm actually a little bit
more in the process
of i would say i'm in the camp of i want
to step on the gas pedal right
i want biden to go as much i want as
much joe biden as possible i want him
giving speeches
24 7. i want him doing live streams you
should bring him on reuben report right
i want him out there all the time
so you just want to exacerbate this is
the point where it'll just be obvious to
everyone that's the idea
like yeah the more body you give us the
less they'll be able to cover it up the
more stories you'll get like this the
more comments you'll get like this where
you know and of course if you if you
push the left on these uh these
statements they'll say well he's clearly
referencing systemic racism and the
the historical injustices that were done
against certain communities of color in
this country
that have created disparities yeah i can
do it right that can
create disparities and access to needed
american
economic and legal institutions and he's
really just a paragon of virtue
it's like no cut the crap right we
everybody knows kamala harris is waiting
in the wings she's either going to wait
for that resignation
or she is going to trigger the 25th
amendment because she wants to be
in that chair steve let's not forget
she was polling at quite literally zero
percent when she stepped out of the
democratic primary but
here we are well her one claim to fame
as a presidential candidate
was successfully calling joe biden a
racist
uh in one of their debates what what i
think we're watching
with this administration is take
take the obama at the obama years and
let's fast forward to
the the current trend of cultural
devolution we're at now compared to
where we were in
2009 2012 etc so accelerated a few more
years but then removed the stagecraft
aspect
of the obama presidency that they were
so effective going back to his
nomination speech his first run where he
had like the greek
columns and he gave the speech there in
uh in la i think it was
they understood the stagecraft they were
the first campaign to jump on
social media i mean when you got a
message from uh from michelle obama we
didn't know what micro targeting and
stuff was you thought she was really
calling you and left you a voicemail
right
they understood the stagecraft and that
that covered a lot of the cloud pivot
sins of his eight years in the white
house
well that's all gone now and now you're
getting all the policy but not of the
none of the pomp
and so you remove all of that stagecraft
you remove the power
of obama's persona his ability to relate
to people communicate to people
all of that is gone now and is replaced
by a construct meaning you get the
policies
but then a guy who as a vehicle is just
riddled with dementia
and i think that's why you're seeing
this thing unravel fast is
is now you don't have to go through
layers of obama's personality in order
to get to the root of an
issue the issues are stripped bare right
away because biden is just not an
effective symbol
yeah i'ma let you know i don't want to
do the identity politics thing but
at some level i mean are you seeing
friends family etc that are just like
like is anyone breaking basically like
have you seen anyone that wasn't really
sure
before the election now be like four
months in and going
boy black people can't get a computer
they can't vote you know they can't get
an id
like all the stuff that we've talked
about here are you seeing some people
that are finally like ah
maybe maybe there's something wrong here
i think it's slowly placing a little
[ __ ] in the armor but we all know the
left and the left does not want to admit
that they're wrong or that they've done
something that has had ramifications
that are poor on society so
it's very hard to truly break through
that barrier of left
of leftism of this massive support for
joe biden
but i think like jack said we just need
to put him on tv more he needs to be
live streaming he needs to be on twitter
he needs to be making youtube videos
because that is going to expose him he
is doing all the work himself
this one's for all of you guys jack i'll
start with you first but are you guys
shocked
that's the way the mainstream media
still runs cover for him
that despite the fact that we can all
see this stuff on twitter and on youtube
and
all of these shows get more views than
cnn we all know that not that that's
that many views
because nobody's watching cnn but that
the mainstream still just they will
not discuss these things when he doesn't
know what he's talking about or when
he's blatantly racist
or when he's bumbling around the stage
or whatever it might be that they still
just don't do it
jack what do you think no i i think it's
different because i think that joe biden
he's just a ratings crusher for them
uh they are all still focused on trump
because the dirty little secret is
he's the only thing keeping any of these
outlets afloat right it's it's all just
anti-trump trump hate uh mueller's gonna
get trump okay maybe mueller's not going
to get him but adam schiff's going to
get him right
they will talk about trump all day long
they want to goad him into running again
they need him to run again if any of
their financial business plans are going
to be able to continue out forward
right that's why they don't talk about
biden because at the end of the day
he's just boring and even people on
their own side don't care about him
steve but just yesterday uh we were told
that trump's telling people he's gonna
be reinstated in august that's what they
said on cnn it must be true
i want to go back to what you just said
about twitter this is where
there is a use for twitter is that
cognitive dissonance
is is can cannot be ignored any longer
because
when we used to have just you know rival
media streams
you could say i was on the air i'm in my
own you know habitat i'm not observing
your ecosystem i don't know what you
guys talk about
but i would say to anybody that's
currently any of the four of us on this
panel go right after we're done here
tweet something incendiary on a few
verboten topics
and i can promise you um that i mean i
i've seen this happen
a bunch of cnn producers or new york
times or washington post reporters
who don't know if my last name is
pronounced dies or dace suddenly
they're on the phone calling me and
asking for clarification
uh did you really mean this i mean what
do you think this means
right and so the idea if they're
pouncing on us
like i'll give you an example dave so i
used to do a lot of panels on cnn and
msnbc just because it was fun
and then the trump era came and they
didn't want to have people like me on
anymore because they just wanted to
further a narrative rather than a
conversation
until trump met with the guy over the
killer over there in north korea and i'm
just not big on
uh palin around with p the p the folks
over there in pyongyang
sure enough after three years of
ignoring me
cnn called me right away to see if i
wanted to come on the network that day
because i didn't like trump's uh entrees
with the north koreans that's an
example of what we're talking about here
and so if they know when we say
something that fits their narrative or
they find incendiary that they can use
against us
that means they're aware of all the
other times we're pointing out when
they're completely full of feces at the
exact same time and yet they just choose
to ignore that what does that tell you
right well i'm you got to be feeling
pretty good about it though because
you're getting in the content creation
game and everyone's ignoring that
nonsense at this point
i know i'm not catching too much heat
right now but i i we all know
revolutionaries they need a villain and
they will move on to somebody after they
move on from trump there will always be
something to fight against and that's
why
these media outlets need some sort of
villain somebody to put in the hot seat
somebody who's evil
well speaking of some sort of villain
the media and the journalists around
town
have made andy know out to be a villain
and andy
it's impossible for me to find someone
who has probably done better
journalistic work
in the last couple years uncovering what
antifa is although jack obviously you've
done a quite job
quite a good job yourself so andy was
attacked in portland by a bunch of
antifa activists the other day this will
not be covered on cnn today
this will not be covered on msnbc and
i'm guessing it ain't going to be in the
new york times
andy sent out a long twitter thread
about it i'm just going to read the two
first ones
and then we're going to show you some
some images of of what happened to him
this is directly from andy himself no
journalist in america should ever face
violence for doing his or her job
yet on friday may 28th antifa tried to
kill me again while i was reporting
on the ongoing protests and riots in
portland oregon for a new chapter of my
book
unmasked inside antifa's radical plan to
destroy democracy
i was chased attacked and beaten by a
masked mob
baying for my blood had i not been able
to shelter
wounded and bleeding inside a hotel
while they beat me
while they beat the doors and windows
like animals there is no doubt in my
mind
i would not be here today their words
like their actions speak for themselves
he went on in the twitter thread and uh
if we can can we throw to some of the
images
uh while i'm mentioning this i as i said
at the top of the show i actually met
andy at that hotel years ago for the
first time first time we ever met each
other he's the most soft-spoken
decent guy you could ever want to meet
this is not someone
that wants to be involved in violence or
inflaming the situation or anything else
uh jack because you're you're you know
writing a book or you just wrote a book
and you're also talking about antifa all
the time
why is this not being covered in an
honest way and what do you think is
andy's responsibility as a journalist
journalist knowing he's going to be
targeted there because i saw a couple
people
who i usually respect their opinions
sort of being like oh no no no he
shouldn't have gone there which is kind
of like telling a woman
she shouldn't you know go out alone at
night
oh yeah well you know to just kind of
answer the second part of that you know
i i would definitely if that were me i'd
you know want to have some security i'd
want to have some backup you know have
them
also be dressed in you know sort of the
the black garb of the black block you
know have them look like you're
infiltrating not carrying weapons or
anything like that unless of course the
black block already is in which case
fine go for it
but yeah um i i get what people are
saying that obviously we
want andy to be safe we we know that we
want people out there watching is back
um i i hope that that's something that
we can you know we can get going in the
future when this comes up because
the real situation is is that when it
comes to this
organization they are an
anarcho-communist syndicate at this
point
that is pushing for violence in all of
these major cities across the country we
saw them in minneapolis again just last
night
and the the not only the media gives
them a pass right
the media will they'll hand out these
little flyers when you go out and they
say if you want to cover one of our
events you have to
abide by our rules and we talk about
this in the book
where you know you can't show our faces
you can't show any action you can't show
any violence you can't show anything
that could identify us and as long as
you
abide by those rules and basically take
our side and everything and don't do
actual journalism then we'll treat you
fine if not
we're gonna put umbrellas in your face
we're going to attack you or like in my
case they're going to we're going to try
to push you down
concrete steps get you to crack your
head open in front of a
statue in lincoln park there in dc and
so when it comes down to it though the
bigger problem
on a higher level is why is the
department of justice
not going after these people we've seen
the way that they've treated january 6
tweeting out the pictures having the
asking people to help identify
where's any of that for antifa they are
just as much insurrectionist insurgents
they're out there night after night and
when it comes to the city of portland
they're attacking
actual federal facilities well weren't
we told that you're allowed to attack
federal facilities as long as it's at
night and nobody's in there wasn't that
literally
the mayor of portland that said that no
it would no unfortunately that was our
attorney general merrick garland who
said that during his uh
oh right right confirmation hearings so
my question is what if it's dusk what if
it's like
right on the cusp of it you know you're
it's like it's like you know before a
hockey game and you're there with the
sticks and you're like ready to go
no right exactly what's silly it's silly
right what if somebody's working late
i mean it is possible i know it's the
government and obviously there are
we know there are people in there
because there were federal agents in the
building at the time so yes
uh attorney general garland there were
people working there they were working
to defend
the courthouse against the thugs that
you won't bring
charges against steve to jack's point i
mean
do you think the feds are going to get
involved i mean
finally the mayor of portland ted
wheeler started pushing back against
them a little bit
after he basically poured gas on the
flames for the last
two years i mean do we need the feds to
be involved why are we letting mass
thugs burn down our cities
crazy question i know i i well i i
thought they should have been dealt with
as a
foreign hostile power for declaring they
had a nine block
uh independent zone last summer frankly
uh and made an example out of
but no they won't be dealt with until or
unless
it impacts the overall leftist narrative
and then that's when
uh they'll learn really quick that the
first rule of assassination is that you
kill the assassins
and i want to go back for just a second
on the cognitive dissonance
aspect and with with andy and and the
bravery of what he has been doing for
these last couple of years
so yesterday my publisher sent me a
piece that the atlantic had written
about uh what had been some of the more
successful conservative books
so far in the biden admit in the biden
era which you know is what's six months
old
and the the highest selling book within
conservative publishing
so far this year is actually andy's book
on antifa and this was mentioned by
mckay coppins
the writer at the atlantic who
specifically mentioned it by name
now where again so you acknow
we i want to make sure we remove all the
innocent motivations here
all right you're citing the success of
this guy's book you're citing that it's
the most successful book
in a genre this entire year so either
he's a total fraud
making a bunch of slanderous and
libelous claims who should be exposed
or he's exposing a thugocracy it's one
or the other
aren't you at least the least bit
intellectually curious
which one it is right and of course the
irony is that everybody that writes a
piece now about andy
in mainstream media or corporate press
whatever you want to call them as
michael malus puts it
they always make a point of saying
conservative journalist andy knows
now i mentioned on twitter i mean i know
andy pretty well he by no means is a
traditional conservative again
he's gay not that you can't be a gay
conservative but the point is i think
he's probably an old school liberal
who's just
been for lack of a better term mugged by
reality in this case
honestly yeah i've i've talked to andy a
million times
i have no idea what his politics are
yeah
he's a journalist so i don't know
because we've
he's never even brought it up yeah i'm
totally with you on that i mean i have a
slight inkling on some things but in no
way when they say conservative it's
they're trying to paint him
as as something that he probably is not
um what about just the general idea that
either journalists can now be attacked
or just what we saw in new york
and in la in the last couple weeks that
you can just attack random people on the
streets and
that this this right seems like it's
being
uh exacerbated it's just a sad state of
affairs that
now look at all the bad journalism that
is happening right now with mainstream
media that goes completely unaccountable
and you have andy noe who is a great
journalist who is doing very good work
and is simply telling the truth and that
is his reward for what he's doing
and anybody who comes out and says
anything that criticizes the left
especially the extreme left
is labeled a conservative journalist
even though like you said he's not very
apparent about where he
lies politically and it's a very sad
state of affairs and we see all these
politicians who say well antifa is just
an idea it doesn't represent a terrorist
organization
they're not doing anything domestically
that's causing any harm to america
but last time i checked ideas don't mob
people they don't
trample them and beat them down in the
streets right well exactly i mean if any
of these things that we've seen in the
last two years could be linked back to
trump supporters as jack pointed out
uh after what happened on the six it was
it would be like they'd be telling us
we're in world war three
jack do you think we're going to find
links between
antifa and the democratic party or at
least
some something more tangible than they
seem to tacitly support them
well so what you really see in the in
the dichotomy or i should say like the
dynamic between
antifa and the democrat party is
that antifa exists to be that leading
edge the tip of the spear
of the overton window with antifa talk
about this and
go to antifa book.com and see it um
shameless in the shameless book
and uh what you see is then the
democrats are increasingly the dsa word
antifa recruits from
uh you know it's really just in many
cases the dsa at night with masks
and black shirts on but they can say
well look we're not as extreme as antifa
we don't want to
abolish the police we just want to
change the funding we just want to
tweak a few things you can actually see
joe biden do this
in real time when they ask him about
some of these antifa dsa slogans where
he says
oh no i just want to i just want to
recommit things i want to change it so
that's exactly how you see antifa
working and by the way
when people tell me is antifa just an
idea right
i look at them and i say well radical
islam is just an idea but you know what
they've got cells they've got groups
they've got organizations and they
commit terrorist attacks so yeah they're
an idea
that forms a movement that starts a
network that has splinter cells
that gets people hurt and gets people
killed so sure why not
but if you you sound like a lunatic if
you you just saying that
in 2021 that native is just an idea yeah
great point steve as a guy that tries to
communicate
these ideas to people um
what can we do to actually show people
that this thing is exactly what jack
just pointed out and not just some
amorphous idea
i think they have to be confronted on a
legal matter
political matter uh on a military matter
frankly
i think they should be treated if they
if it was islam that claimed to occupy
nine city blocks of a major american
city i would assume
we would treat that as a hostile
invading force and
one of the things that's puzzled me
about antifa this entire time is it just
me
okay but every time one of these kids
gets one of these guys gets unmasked
doesn't it look like when we were in
youth football and you're like
slowly going into the line you're sizing
up when the oklahoma drills coming up
and you're like
i don't want to be opposite this guy so
let me let these three guys go ahead of
me
every one of them's like the dweeb you
gave swirlies to in the locker room
right it's like they specifically target
guys who are taking
humanities or women's studies with a why
in college
301 and think and fantasize at night
about being a badass because
uh they they played some military
first-person shooter game once i mean
why do all of these guys whenever
they're unmasked look like complete and
total dweebs wait actually i want to
before i give them all of the final word
i want to ask jack that very question
because when you see these pictures of
these people when they finally are
unmasked
steve's totally right and also it seems
that a huge
percentage of them are on drugs and we
know that there's obviously an opioid
and fentanyl
crisis right now do you have any info on
that like how many of these people are
actually hooked on drugs and
how how that is all connected so when i
when i was in chaz you know we talked
about this in the book as well but when
i spent
uh you know the several days and nights
out there i mean drugs were plentiful
people were coming up to us you know
because we're dressed in uh
uh in sort of the the appropriate attire
for the chas
and people were coming up there's at one
point a guy came up to me with a a
trashcan lid that was turned upside down
and he had just various types of drugs
on it uh everything from weed to shrooms
to stuff that i didn't even know about
and he was just hey do you want some
partake my brethren right and then he
sort of just
he was on on rollerblades and he just
skated off to somewhere else that was
the kind
of atmosphere you had in there there was
a homeless encampment
where drugs were absolutely plentiful
that led to people getting killed people
getting stabbed in that homeless camp
so i mean this was a huge part and
parcel of exactly what was going on
because
partially it specifically with chaz it
wasn't even so much
that it was the activist bringing it in
from antifa but once you told people
that hey there's a
crime free or you know i should say a
law law enforcement free area
those criminal elements those drug
elements all of that was coming and
congregating within that chat zone
i keep going to you as the young person
get given me some hope here
but do you think that young people are
watching this going
ah maybe law and order ain't that
terrible maybe we should
actually fund police maybe we should
arrest people for
committing murder and that sort of thing
i would
certainly hope so but i think the issue
is is that social media
mainstream media and even now our public
schooling systems are pushing
children and young people to be these
sort of radical
vessels for the left and as much as the
left wants to say that
schools are a school-to-prison pipeline
right now they are a school to
radicalism pipeline
and they're teaching the children this
sort of ideology the gender theory the
crt
and it is pushing them to act like the
antifa members out in portland and it's
very unfortunate and it's something that
has really run rampant within portland
schools through the research that i've
done
and i think we're leaning more towards
that within our public institutions and
that's where young people are being
influenced
i think in short we got work to do hey
listen i want to thank the three you
guys we're going to link to all of your
stuff
right down below i'm going to say to you
say goodbye to you and i'm just gonna
babble on to the good people for a
little bit and and wish them a good
weekend
so thank you to you three and uh for the
rest of you still watching
uh all right the weekend is here it was
a it was a weird week this was a really
weird week you know
some of the weeks are weird some of them
are hostile some of them are crazy
this one i would say was weird i mean
the fouchy email stuff above everything
else
sort of this like endless leak of oh we
kind of didn't know what we were doing
the stuff that we addressed at the top
of the show
especially the mask stuff that was why
that was the one email that we selected
for this show
because there's a lot of sort of insider
scientific stuff that it's hard to
understand
exactly who he's talking to what the
exact context is
but i thought the basic idea of yeah the
masks that you buy at the store
don't really work and the droplets get
through it's like you guys told us to
wear masks
this whole time although at the
beginning you told us not to and then
you told us too
and then you told us to wear two masks
and everything else and
i know i repeat myself every now and
again and i apologize if you've heard me
say this before but that is why i
constantly say
we're in a war on truth because it is it
is so incumbent on you like it's now
becoming almost like a second job if you
have a first job
if you're fortunate enough to have a
first job right now but it's becoming
like a second job to basically
ascertain what the truth is because you
read stuff
and if you're if every day you're
walking around going
oh i read something in the new york
times i read something in cnn etc and
this is true
and then it consistently happens that
three months later you find out it's not
true
and we know that this has happened
russia hoax covington kids
brett kavanaugh's a racist jessie
smallette
trump tried to tell the attorney general
of georgia to flip the results of the
election like
the the endless cascade of things that
turn out not to be true
it's like now it's on us to figure it
out and how you stay sane in that
um is the great challenge of our time
and i will continue trying
to do it with you uh i just want to say
one other thing before
uh before the weekend although i've got
a whole bunch of other things to do and
i
assume some of you do too um which is
that i did an event at
uh the heritage foundation yesterday
which was really fantastic in
austin texas and it was just great to be
in austin the weather was
bananas i mean it was like electrical
storms
lightning i felt like i was in a sci-fi
movie the whole time however i gave a
talk at
the heritage foundation i actually gave
the keynote address ted cruz was there
got to see him for a few minutes
and chat um and during my speech there
was a q a after
and one of the themes that just kept
coming up and it's just it's
so consistent with everything else going
on it's like what can i do what can i do
well i do sense more people are speaking
up i tweeted out this great video of a
woman
a mother in new york she's like this
like prototypical
italian mom right out of jersey or new
york
fighting critical race theory at a
at her local you know school board event
and just fighting them and telling them
what they are
and we need more and more people to step
up actually in about an hour from now
uh i'm interviewing if you i hope you've
seen it and if you haven't seen it
you're gonna see it but there was a
video that went super viral this week i
had a little something to do with it by
pushing out so many times
of of a young father who happens to be a
black man with his young daughter who
happens to be
a great young girl she's probably three
or four years old
and he's talking to her about what it
means really to be a person and not
believe in critical race theory and
judge people as individuals
and she's just so funny and perfect and
light and truthful and wonderful and i i
immediately
did everything i could do to to contact
them and say listen i want to i want to
amplify this message
so we're going to sit down with corey
and his daughter in just a little bit
and we're going to put it up today
and that's how we fight back whether
it's going to your school board and
telling them what the truth is
or putting a video out with your
daughter or being brave enough at
any given moment to just when you when
somebody's saying something crazy at the
dinner table
and usually you just sit on your hands
and go ah i'm just not in the mood but
maybe push back a little bit i'm not
saying you know you got to throw the
soup in their face
at the beginning at least i mean
sometimes after an hour it can be enough
but i think you get my point that we all
we all play a part
in this thing oh and then the final
point is this that between the fouchy
stuff
this week and some of the more
ridiculous biden comments and everything
else and now trump back on facebook and
instagram
which is only two weeks after they said
that they weren't going to revisit it
for what six months or a year they said
they were going to keep him off
and now they've decided that he's back
on it's like
maybe there is a shift here and i think
what jack said was really interesting
which is
they need trump right i mean they
obviously need trump their ratings are
tanking and facebook and instagram are
suddenly going
oh man if we don't put trump back on
here well maybe he is going to start his
own platform
or maybe he's going to join locals or
maybe some other thing is going to
happen who knows
all sorts of weird things can happen so
we better get the guy back on here
before we let go of our monopoly so
anyway my point all this is there's some
interesting stuff happening guys
and uh and we're all part of it and i
look forward to being on the adventure
with you
so that is it for me we will be back
with that interview with corey and
and his daughter i i just can't wait to
talk to her like just
absolutely phenomenal uh have a great
weekend everybody enjoy yourselves
maybe not too much politics this weekend
get out there
eat some good food listen to some good
music be with some people you you like
maybe even love
that's it see you on monday